Місто Невер у французькій Бургундії.
Трирічна Раіна квапиться до так званої "материнської школи".
По суті, це дитсадок, але у Франції це є першим етапом шкільної освіти
Тут малюки вчаться читати, а з чотирьох років - рахувати і писати.
Діти можуть самі обирати собі заняття.
Але я стежу за тим, щоб вони отримували необхідні знання.
Обов'язкова шкільна освіта в Україні - з шести років.
А у Франції з нового навчального року в школу зобов'язані ходити вже з трьох років.
Про це оголосив президент країни Еммануель Макрон.
Це - частина його реформ у сфері освіти.
Я сподіваюся, що нова обов'язкова освіта з 2019 року
дасть змогу створити більш рівноправні можливості.
Проблема в тім, що у Франції освітні можливості дітей
дуже сильно залежать від соціального становища батьків.
Разом з тим критики скаржаться й на інше - замало кадрів.
Дошкільний навчальний заклад потрібен для підготовки школяра.
Стати школярем означає навчитися соціальним навикам - це вкрай важливо.
Це німецько-французький дитячий садок у Парижі.
Тут не дуже в захваті від намірів
зробити навчальний план для малюків більш насиченим.
На мою думку, дитсадок має пропонувати більше можливостей для індивідуального розвитку дітей
і більше зосередитися на їхній креативності та музичній активності.
Те, що видається радикальним в інших країнах,
для Франції вже загалом звична практика.
Понад дев'яносто сім відсотків трирічних дітлахів і так відвідують такі "материнські школи".
Тому закон Макрона щодо цього нічого суттєво не міняє.
Гадаю, це логічно і нормально, це ж освіта для дітей
Моя дитина пішла в школу ще раніше, їй було лише два з половиною.
Макрон переконаний, що це забезпечить кращу соціалізацію дітей
та знизить рівень неуспішності в початковій і середній школі.
За пропуск занять батькам малюків загрожуває штраф до 135 євро.